[музика]
Щиро вітаємо вас це програму у
фокусіроповій телекомпанії Deutsche
Welle президент росії Путін Мабуть
уявляв собі все інакше через сім місяців
після початку війни його війська
вимушені оборонятися
українська армія повідомляє про своє
просування на Сході та півдні країни
Путін хоче цьому протистояти і наказав
частково мобілізувати свої збройні сили
щоб додатково відправити на фронт сотні
тисяч солдатів
російський президент хоче всіма силами
переломити хід війни на свою користь те
що зараз Кремль намагається загнати в
армию ще більше придатних до бойової
служби людей жахає все більше громадян
Росії так само молодого Москвича міхаела
він не хоче воювати проти України і
чинить опір призову в запас
Він один із багатьох хто протестує проти
політики Путіна в рідній країні а не
тихо її покидає
[оплески]
ні благодійні скандують вони на вулиці
Москви вийшли сотні демонстранців вони
чинять опір часткові мобілізації
багатьох із них затримують і доставляють
до відділку поліції
серед них також міхаіл музикант і
подкастр йому довелося провести у
відділку 6 годин там його змушували
підписати повістку про призов до армії
Але 29-річний чоловік відмовився
мене вивели в іншу кімнату
там було багато чоловіків двоє з них
були поліцейськими двоє невідомі
вони зачинили кімнату зсередини і почали
говорити що я ніхто
принижували мене штовхали і навіть били
мені довелося через це пройти але
зрештою я вийшов із відділку нічого не
підписавши
і тепер я очікую що ж буде далі
після арешту міхаел живе у друга він
майже не виходить і ховається від
поліції
Михаил підпадає під часткову мобілізацію
оскільки проходив військову службу
але він і з самого початку був проти
війни
жодного варіанту для мого призову не
існує Я краще піду в колонію ніж на
війну
Росія зазнала в Україні великих
військових втрат нові війська за їхнім
задумом мають переломити ситуацію
Міноборони Росії говорить про 300 тисяч
досвідчених військових Але критики
кажуть що мобілізація особливо в
провінції проводиться набагато масовіше
і без чітких умов втім чоловіки без
військової підготовки зокрема інший
Міхеіл воювати бояться вони кажуть нам
їдьте туди
Але чи ми коли-небудь повернемося і їм
байдуже ми гарматне м'ясо
мета цієї мобілізації очевидно полягає в
тому щоб виграти великою кількістю
гарматного м'яса поки з якістю не
вдається
у Москві і закордон він тікати не хоче
навіть якщо залишатися в Росії
ризиковано
Я відчуваю своєрідний внутрішній потяг
Мені не подобається те що тут
відбувається і я хочу оборонятися
[музика]
Мені здається що все ще є надія і
перспектива
бо якщо тут у Росії нікого не залишиться
Та ніхто і не зможе щось змінити
Михаил хоче продовжувати виходити на
вулиці і протестувати проти путінської
війни навіть якщо йому як іншим
демонстратам загрожує до 15 років
в'язниці
війна проти України переростає також в
економічну війну Росії і заходом Росія
припинила або сильно обмежила постачання
газу до Європи
Європейський союз прийняв рішення про
частковим баргом російського нафту тобто
заборонив імпорт нафти морським шляхом
але це нафтовим баргом має лозівку і
вона знаходиться в лаконський Затоці
біля берегів Греції тут саме грецькі
танкири допомагають російській
військовій машині
Світанок на узбережжі півострова
пелопоннес
тодоріс хондроянус зі своїми колегами із
дослідницькою мережі репортерс Юнайтед
на шляху у лаконську Затоку
там у міжнародних водах вони хочуть
задокументувати брудну оборудку
оборудку для путінської Росії
ми досліджуємо так звані операції судна
на судно
це означає перевантаження нафти з одного
танкера на інший
після нападу Росії на Україну ми
з'ясували що саме тут усе частіше
здійснюється такі снс оборудки
журналісти-розслідувачі тижня ми стежили
за подіями у лаконській Затоці за
допомогою інтернет-трекерів
більшість танків приходять сюди через
Чорне море завантажені російською нафтою
танкери під російським прапором не
можуть прямувати до європейських портів
через самці у майбутньому є повністю
заборонить ввозити російську нафту
наблизившись репортери помічають ознаки
того що вперше передача ось-ось
відбудеться
там танкер уже опустив такі величезні
коли подібні кранці Вони мають запобігти
зіткненню двох танкерів під час
перекачування
між двома іншими танками перекачування
вже йде повним ходом
праворуч танкер що приймає російську
нафту він належить грецькій судноплавній
компанії адже на цій спробі замаскувати
походження російської нафти заробляють
передусім грецькі судновласники
з боку судновласників багато лицемірства
грецькі телеканали якими вони володіють
засуджують війну проти України
одночасно вони ведуть бізнес із
російською нафтою по всьому світу
оскільки перекачування відбувається у
міжнародних водах воно не є незаконним
такою є позиція судновласників однак
грецька асоціація судновласників від
інтерв'ю щодо цього відмовилася
не вбачає у цьому проблему для своєї
країни також їх грецька опозиція Афіни
не можуть вжити заходів проти порушників
санкцій за межами своїх морських
кордонів необхідне втручання
Європейського Союзу
адже російська нафта іде не до Греції
а опиняється зрештою десь у Європі тому
подбати Про це має Європейський союз
Утім наразі на південному краю
пелопонесу продовжують перевантажувати
величезні обсяги сирої нафти цілодобово
також спостерігає за тим що відбувається
з іншою причини
хоча еколога тут хвилюють не лише погано
захищені місця розмноження морських
черепах журналістам розслідувачем віза
Фін Він розповідає
ми боїмося аварії танкера
це б забруднуло всю територію тут нафтою
Ми живемо туризмом з природи та історії
У нас тут немає ні промисловості ні
Великого сільського господарства розлив
нафти знищить тут усе що ми маємо
ця власниця житла для відпочинку
стурбована ще й тим що грецькі
судновласники своєю діяльністю ставлять
під загрозу її бізнес
Мій готель на відпочинковий комплекс
добудували лише Минулого року ще тоді в
нас була проблема через збитки внаслідок
лісових пожеж тепер ще й загроза розливу
нафти це стане як екологічною так і
економічною катастрофою
Репортер хондро Янус скаржиться що
перекачування російської нафти за
допомогою Греції для продажу її на
світовому ринку не є важливою темою для
обговорення у грецьких ЗМІ
але цей не дивно
компанії по-різному контролюють медіа
наприклад через розподіл реклами або
тому що вони володіють акціями медіа
Вони настільки політично сильні що
більшість журналістів вважає за краще
про них не писати
Утім журналісти розслідувачів ввечері
знову на варті
російську нафту в лаконській Затоці
перекачують також і вночі
Так біля берегів Греції наповнюється
військова скарбниця Москви
гаманці інших навпаки стають порожніми
висока інфляція та цінна на енергоносії
проривають великі діри в бюджетах
багатьох людей у Великій Британії
зростає кількість людей які більше не
можуть оплачувати рахунки за газ та
електроенергію Такі люди як Наташа та
Гері почуваються кинутими політиками
напризволяще і вони бояться наближення
зими
Ісла боніта так що називають Канарський
острів лапальма після потужного
виверження вулкану рік тому частини
красивого острова перетворилися на
нереальний місячний пейзаж
багато жителів втратили свої домівки
засоби до існування та спогади але вони
люблять свою чарівну батьківщину і радше
беруться до роботи ніж зневіряються на
красивій зовнішності острова лапальма
з'явилася пляма але життя на пороховій
бочці продовжується
прямо Через лавове поле коли він їде по
цій тимчасовій дорозі це відчувається як
покарання каже фермер Віктор боніла
зараз Ми якраз їдемо через одну з
бананових плантацій яка раніше належала
мені
праворуч досі щось є
А так це все що залишилося тут і
плантації
Вхід заборонено знаки попереджають на
узбіччі все ще спека до 70 градусів
повітря мерехтить над потоком із каміння
минув один рік з того моменту як вулкан
на канарському острові лапальма вивергав
Вогонь і поховав 4000 будівель вулиці та
бананові плантації
тисячі сімей на лапальма живуть із
вирощування продуктів на землі
у грудні вулкан заспокоївся але не люди
на острові
наша теперішня проблема попіл на землі а
також і на рослинах
минув рік але подивіться що ще
залишається бачите проблеми яку ми маємо
наразі все добре але що нам робити Невже
за допомогою пластикового пакета
запобігати проникненню цього пилу в
рослину
безпосередньо біля плантації є Що інша
проблема
після виверження вулкана фахівці
помітили що тут із землі виходить газ
тому певні місця у пуерту наус все ще
перегороджені
пожежна команда дозволяє нам бути
присутніми під час вимірювання наша
група на безпечній відстані від
сигнального приладу
сюди вам не можна
тут занадто високі показники
[музика]
на землі концентрація СО2 найвища тут
під загрозою були передусім діти
пояснюють пожежники та особливо
небезпечно не на вулиці А в будинках
мешканцям дозволили приходити у місто
лише на 2-3 години після погодження із
пожежною охороною щоб забрати Речі зі
своїх закладів або квартир
за кілька кварталів технічний директор
пожежної охорони
якщо ти перебуваєш у місті десь годину
то нічого не відбувається
проблем зі здоров'ям не виникає
але якщо 24 години на добу вдень і вночі
тоді ніхто не може гарантувати людям
здоров'я
деякі жителі острова називають
пуертонаус маленькі Чорнобиль саме тут
на західному узбережжі лапальми ще й
досі знаходиться Майже 2000 гостьових
ліжок які зараз не можуть
використовувати через газ при цьому
після виверження вулкана лапальмі
знадобилося більше ліжок для гостей адже
вулкан приваблює багатьох туристів які
хочуть використати відпустку на походи
та відкриття чогось нового багато
походів у вулканічну зону надовго
заброньовані лапальма цього літа
перевищила туристичний прогноз
Ми хочемо побачити острів нашу увагу
привернув вулкан це зовсім новий досвід
якому як на іншій планеті
але на території яка зараз захоплює так
багато людей допускають лише досвідчених
гідів
оскільки в безпосередній близькості від
вулкана стає небезпечно
хоча наразі нове виверження не загрожує
розповідає ставрос мелитлідіс який
постійно відчуває пульс вулкана
однієї загроз є наприклад нестабільність
рельєфу
він швидко охолонув а це означає що
земля все ще рухається
потім гази в самому конусі викиди
нестабільні
вони можуть змінюватися і раптово
підійматися до того ж ми маємо ще й
високі температури
як і унизу на тимчасовій дорозі по якій
їздить Віктор боніла
пальма через рік після виверження
вулкана хвилювань багато але туристи
приносять також і надію
надію має також і маленькі Містечко у
глухих лісах Фінляндії поганка тут ще
проживає менш ніж 3000 жителів і
тенденція падає
місто яке Здається було приречено на
занепад якби не Ці двоє молодих
чоловіків сантері та оскарі
вони хочуть знову зробити своє місто
привабливим але як це втілити особливо
зі ставленням до життя коли завжди бачиш
лише все негативне обидва стали
свідомими песимістами і все-таки даються
йому місту зовсім нову перспективу
[музика]
цей бар уже давно закрився
від цієї крамниці залишилось лише два
стільці
а далі ще й попередження за містом
Незабаром ви досягнете поланки але ви ще
можете повернути і назад
[музика]
поланка маленьке містечко всередині
Фінляндії що вмирає поки що тут лишилося
2400 жителів
більшості за 60
молодь залишає поле Ланку
вірними своєму місту залишаються тільки
ці двоє
оскарі і сантері з місцевого товариства
песимістів
адже саме в песимізмі закладений шанс на
новий початок
[музика]
ми визнали що не можемо відродити
поланку
ми не сумуємо через те що місто вмирає
ми дивимося на це з боку гумору і хочемо
щоб люди над цим сміялися
Хто сказав що песимісти завжди повинні
виглядати так
чому песиміст не може також і
посміхатися
саме песимісти повернули по оланці трохи
надії
добре відвідують тепер не лише кав'ярню
песиміст
у сусідній крамниці туристи купують
футболки та значки спасимістичними
посланнями
своєрідне місто оскарі та його друзі
прославили також і само іронічними
музичними відео
тому поланка стала у Фінляндії культом
це весело типовий фінський гумор
на цій футболці написано Сьогодні я
пригнічений і мене це влаштовує А ще
Пенсійний фонд щойно повідомив що моя
Пенсія буде збільшена на три відсотки
тобто щомісячно на цілих 2 євро більше
факти говорять проти майбутнього для
міста з 1980-х років кількість жителів
зменшилася більш ніж удвічі з кожним
роком вона зменшується дедалі більше тут
ще досі є школи дитсадки і будинок для
людей похилого віку
але питання хто хоче жити десь у глибині
фінських лісів
але природа в пооланці справді чудова
каже мер кампанія песимізму підвищила
впізнаваність їхнього міста
відтоді він переконаний що кількість
мешканців незабаром знову почне
збільшуватися
Я вважаю що все більше людей хочу жити в
регіонах де є чиста природа і багато
місця для життя
а місце в нас вистачає фактично один
квадратний кілометр на людину тому
переживати через сусідів не доводиться
та сантері кажуть що вони насправді
відносяться в пооланці до найщасливіших
людей
зрештою у світовому звіті про щастя фіни
в 5 поспіль визнані найщасливішими
людьми на землі
це ж підходить до песимізму люди тут не
очікують багато і задоволені навіть
малим
якби ми мали справді серйозні проблеми
то ми мабуть не поширювали смішні
розповіді про песимізм
займалися б іншими справами
песимізм як бренд
невідомо чи можна буде врятувати поланку
від занепаду
але мешканці принаймні спробували і з
оптимізмом і гумором
Отже фінський песимізм - це коли над ним
все одно сміються
А це була програма У фокусі Європи
телекомпанії Deutsche Welle Дякуємо за
ваші інтерес як завжди ви можете ще раз
передивитися нашу програму наші домашній
сторінці в інтернеті На все добре до
побачення
українською мовою озвучено центром
медіа-ініціативу переклад Володимира та
Олесі Швед режисер Павло Тимченко так
читали Олена потоцька Юрій Лисенко та
Олесь гоян Київ 2022 рік
[музика]